In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for August 21st, on which we commemorate the Holy Apostle
Thadius.
On the 21st of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Apostle Thadius.
The Holy Apostle Thadius, sometimes called Levi, came from the town of Edison, in Ossron,
of a Jewish family from which he received an excellent knowledge of the Holy Scriptures.
He went on pilgrimage to Jerusalem, and having heard St. John the Baptist preaching repentance
and being filled with enthusiasm for his angelic way of life, he was baptized by him.
Sometime later, he met the Lord Jesus Christ.
The amazing miracles that he brought and his sublime teaching gave Thadius the conviction that
he was the Savior, proclaimed both by John and the prophets.
And so he joined his disciples and followed Jesus right up to his life-giving passion.
In conformity with the promise that the Lord had given King Akbar who had asked him to
go and heal him, he sent Thadius to Edison to baptize the King and completely heal him
of his leprosy.
The zealous Apostle catacized and baptized many more of the people of the kingdom, which
was the first state to declare itself Christian.
He had many churches built there, and then went on with his mission and proclaimed the good
news in other towns in Syria and some say in Mesopotamia.
Arriving in Burithus, in Phoenicia, he baptized a great many pagans there before giving his
soul into God's hands in peace, receiving the recompense of the faithful servant of his
grace.
St. Thadius' relics were translated to Constantinople together with those of the Apostle Andrew
by St. Artemius in the year 337 through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ
our God, have mercy on us and save us.